le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais la musique a
toujours pris une grande place dans le
coeur des réunionnais à travers le
maloya le séga les artistes réunionnais
raconte l'histoire de la réunion
véhicule leur culture et ses valeurs
originales ces artistes de talent et
d'univers différents ne sont pas
forcément connus du grand public alors
qu'ils ont des messages importants à
faire passer de l'autre côté nombre de
collégiens ont des talents qu'ils ne se
connaissent pas ils peuvent les exprimer
parfois à travers la musique
alors comment aider ces artistes à
transmettre le patrimoine musical
réunionnais comment faciliter les
rencontres entre le monde artistique et
le monde éducatif
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
est artiste auteur chanteur et
interprète
passionné par son art il m en parler et
en faire profiter la jeunesse
réunionnaise
il a donc répondu présent à l'invitation
du conseil général pour l'opération
collège en musique organisée pour la
troisième fois cette année
entre quelques scènes de spectacle jim
échange et partage sa passion avec des
collégiens
ces moments passés avec ses jeunes lui
permettent de transmettre ce patrimoine
musical qu'il a lui même reçu des
instants privilégiés très agréable pour
les collégiens mais aussi pour jim car
pour un artiste ce qui compte avant tout
c'est de recevoir de l'affection de la
part de son public
que ce soit dans une grande salle de
spectacle ou dans une salle de classe
ba ni faire un petit tour dans le
collège des aigrettes à saint gilles
pour une intervention
ici pour parler de l'album de ma façon
de travailler
la musique et tout ça et bien sûr
d'essayer de faire petite représentation
avec les élèves avec des chansons de l
amp a pris on voit que c'est oui
il se pose des questions ce qu'assure
sur ce qui se passe pour un musicien
dire et surtout voilà comment ça a
commencé
c'est en tout cas pour moi c'était un
bon moment là dessus parce qu'on sent
n'y avait pas le bardage qu'on a
d'habitude bas sauf qu'encore une bêtise
ou des trucs comme ça mais voilà au
général il était très attentif il
écoutait
ce que j'apprécie c'est surtout bac qui
chante déjà mes chansons c'est axa.ax
avec ça ça fait chaud au coeur et en
classe ils chantaient vraiment il
chantait ce n'est pas dans leur tonalité
c'est vrai mais chanter quand même ce
bonheur partagé avec les collégiens est
bien plus qu'un échange c'est une
transmission de savoir et d'histoire
la musique fait pleinement partie du
patrimoine d'un pays à travers elle et
ces artistes nous pouvons ressentir les
douleurs les joies les émotions qu'ont
pu connaître les anciennes générations
grâce à la musique
l'histoire de la réunion continue de
s'écrire et c'est dans ces moments de
partage quand un artiste va à la
rencontre de la nouvelle génération que
la passation se fait à moi c'est super
parce que on a pu le rencontrer en vrai
un artiste sur lequel on avait travaillé
et
c'est sympa aussi sa part j'ai pu venir
pour nous dans collège vu qu'il y avait
pas beaucoup de monde s'était c'était
bien parce qu'on a plus
on a pu lui parler lui poser des
questions et il a répondu avec plaisir
donc c'était super et c'était votre
passé une bonne expérience pour nous
parce que
il a pu voir un chanteur fait le vrai
alors le collège en partenariat avec le
conseil général a décidé de s'inscrire
dans la fête de la musique est donc de
proposer à l'ensemble des élèves de cet
établissement une intervention de jim
fortuné donc un petit concert à 10h et
puis aussi une intervention pédagogique
en amont pour présenter le travail de
l'artiste qui est sur un fil conducteur
sur toute la journée ce qui permet à la
fois pas d'éveiller les élèves sur cette
fête de la musique sur la culture qui
nous paraît extrêmement important et
puis de créer un événement de fin
d'année fédérateur pour tous ces élèves
ces moments entre jeunes collégiens et
artistes locaux sont importants pour la
réunion
ils permettent de consolider la
solidarité cette belle valeur humaine
grande particularité de notre île le
conseil général en a bien conscience et
initie puis soutien des dispositifs tels
que ces interventions d'artistes locaux
dans les établissements scolaires
réunionnais pour nassimah dindar
ces rencontres sont importantes pour
faciliter les échanges
l'émergence de talents et de vocations
l'ouverture des collégiens sur le monde
culturel
la fête de la musique ça n'est pas
seulement des grands concerts avec les
excellents artistes réunionnais que nous
avons c'est aussi l'occasion pour le
conseil général
de mettre en avant un artiste parfois
pas suffisamment connue des jeunes et
donner envie à ces jeunes de s'exprimer
de montrer qu'ils ont aussi des
potentialités des talents c'est la
troisième édition de la fête de la
musique dans les collèges et 20 collèges
cette année ont participé pour cette
belle rencontre
moi je crois qu'il faut non seulement
encourager l'ouverture de la culture
c'est dans ce sens là que le conseil
général nous aidons les collèges et les
artistes se rencontrer lors de la fête
de la musique
comme beaucoup de dispositifs mis en
place par le conseil général
collège en musique permet aux
réunionnais de consolider certaines
valeurs humaines qui font la richesse de
la réunion le conseil général de la
réunion vous a présenté lien social le
conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais